Depending on what sort of input data
we provide when this string is read,
we know that if we provide more that
12 bytes, we're going to overflow
in this direction into these
variables as we're talking about.
So what can you do if you,
sort of, are careful about it?
First thing that we want to do is,
we want program control to go someplace
where our code, the attacker
can actually craft some code.
There are two things
the attacker has to do.
It has to have its code that it wants to
run, and then it has to find a way to
get the program control transfer to
happen, such that the program goes and
starts executing the code that
the attacker has crafted.
Here, we should sort of look at this and
say there is an opportunity here for
the attacker.
The attacker has found a way to go
up and write into this locations.
We know that it has done that, because
if it passes more than 12 bytes these 4
bytes are going to be overwritten,
that's allowed login.
If it writes more than 16 bytes, then
the return address is gona be And so
if we carefully sort of overflow, and
you can find out the return
address where our code is.
And the overflow actually ends up
writing the address of that code
into this return address.
What would happen in that case?
The function, when it's done,
will not return to where it came from.
Remember it had stored the address where
it needs go back in return address.
But by carefully sort of overflowing and
modifying this return address,
that old return address is history.
It's gone.
It's going to actually return to
the address that we have inserted or
we have put in these 4 bytes.
The 4 bytes where we have
the new address that we have put
in to this area of memory where we
have the return address before.
That's where this program
is going to return.
So this is kind of an ha moment.
By providing bad input,
the vulnerability is,
we're going to know that,
we're not checking input.
That's the vulnerability.
That is what is going
exploited by that hacker.
The attacker is providing
a carefully crafted input.
And when we take that input,
an overflow occurs.
And the way the overflow reaches
the return address area,
the part of memory where
the return address is stored.
We are actually going to put a new
return address where code that we have
created, by we I mean the attacker, the
program will start executing that code.
So some code that hacker wants executed,
if we know where that code is, and
we know its address, and this is what
we override these four locations with,
the return address by passing bad input,
exploiting the vulnerability, when
the program doesn't check it's input.
By passing carefully crafted input,
we are now able to take the program
from where it was to a place where
our instructions are located.